they make way for the hall of famer the
NBA on TNT analyst Shaquille O'Neal
where are you today oh did you shoot
your role in the Sandler movie yeah yeah
I am I'm the school principal I shot
mine a couple of weeks ago what's your
role I'm a DJ DJ with a funny voice can
I hear this noise you mean funny and
sexy che so you just did one day up
there on Sandler's movie cent yeah
that's you see that's about it the
over-under is 12 that was what I would
think I was on there for 14 hours and
you stand around and you don't do
anything yeah
so help me understand all of this with
you know you and Kobe everything's good
right this is just fun back and forth is
this normal for you guys of course what
was your reaction when you first heard
that you didn't I think four no three oh
three I guess you left your laptop
available yes okay give me my averages
you can even start at 99 or 2000 so just
doing my opera just people TPG all right
Shaquille O'Neal started out in 90 you
know way back with the magic in 1995 a
29.0 game okay ninety nine twenty nine
point seven points per game thirteen
points six rebounds I can't find one
thank you so go twenty eight point seven
and twelve point seven rebounds
okay so file another sooner or fall for
whose world war can't okay lecture
twenty seven point two ten point seven
we're gonna be here awhile okay who is
your rival nobody me I was my old rival
and you know what people don't need to
understand is that when I came in early
that the time being the best floats
around to lecture me you know the way
one year is Mike one years it's let's
call me one year supply audience me the
terrible whatever booth is the most time
whatever I think it's fair to say I own
that term
Wilkinson where the game is being played
around now yeah the way they gave us a
way around
that's her will never be messed with
again do you think that that there's a
little truth in the kidding there that
Kobe has about calling you lazy like
dizzy did he really feel that way mm oh
one twenty seven point two points no
thank you alright was David Robinson
arrival yeah a team yes Tim Duncan Spurs
the Spurs whole organization but do I go
to the gym seven hours a day no never
don't need to for who and I and how come
you took a shot at Dwight Howard yeah it
says all good bro when I saw the
interview I thought you were talking
about Dwight and then you spell a DWI
teehee
and then you put lol no I love the
the way that me and Kobe those guy he's
a business guy oh it's a different
Dwight okay my bad
my my bad what do you think of the
Lakers signing Dwight Howard my only
advice to him is he needs to dig dig
deep really deep I know as a big man is
his work hard he wants to win a
championship
and he can get it done McLovin I did
some more math for you okay but what
year do you want here's young when I
want to share we ship in 2006 I was born
in 1972 how old how old would that make
me 34 okay and Dwight is how old is he
34 34 no 33 33 so my message to the
great Dwight Howard is I know
everybody's counting you out and
everybody's messing with you but if you
dig deep down and play with that anger
and players that ferocity they stop
kidding around and you know use LeBron
and kind of cool because you're actually
got a good team right you know if Miami
I was 34 so mr. Wyatt on my way out
people thought I was washed up when I
left LA but I dug deep down I said you
know what I can do this so if he does
everything like he's supposed to do
focus no joking no play there's just dig
deep down I really really wanted they
could possibly win the big podcast with
Shaq has new episodes available every
Monday on podcast 1.com sorry
interrupting he doesn't know yet but he
is the missing like do you were I was
telling this story I don't know a couple
of days ago where we were handing out
the MVP trophy and the finals when you
were with Miami Heat and you walked up
behind me and you said that can you hand
out the trophy to Dwyane Wade do you
remember that why was it so important
for you to hand him that MVP trophy
conversations all year but being the man
his team his team I was just passing the
torch yeah it's a nice moment but I I
thought I don't know what you're gonna
do I'm you're like hey let me uh let me
hand the trophy - no I thought you were
gonna take the trophy and do something
with it so I'm glad I'm glad that your
professional there finals but Pat Riley
there put together a hell of a team and
I just kept everybody together and
here's some great pieces and you know
you know the spiel I just gave about
Dwight yes also a guy my team who did
the same thing a guy by the name of
Alonzo Mourning so when I was applying a
while allowing someone who had that fire
and he's carrying us and like every time
I see him I like him a bigger and say
thanks man so he was alert a lower
despair movement I mean I was playing
okay I was averaging I don't know what
else I wasn't happy shacking it was but
D way was fabulous you know all the
others play well and Alonzo like when I
was comin Coakley Bay she was a big
fella I got you he brought us here big
fella
now watch me go to work so my message is
dividers just you know use that he was
us he was me and Alonzo to get it up
because I actually wanted to get it done
we weren't what I was looking at you're
a business resume and I'm curious when
like who helped you understand the
business world where I think you liked
Krispy Kreme or Papa John's like you you
invest or buy those properties who
taught you to do this
welcome every aspect of my life so one
day I was looking at an article because
you know came across my phone and it's
at the top business guys to stop playing
basketball and in my mind I'm gonna
to be number one right so when I open
the list I was number four I really I
really take me off it was me Magic
Johnson Michael Jordan of course and the
first name was junior Bridgeman I was a
junior Bridgeman from the Bucks yeah
and I looked at what he was doing I was
like wow it's a super impressive so you
know throughout my career I watched
magic I watched a vein I watched Michael
Jordan a sight that I even watch Isiah
Thomas and how he conducts his business
so you know past my past five years or
so I was like you know I want to be the
next junior Bridgeman you always gotta
have a young boy mentality you know say
go for yourself in high school I want to
be they were up in high school I want to
be Patrick you know high school I want
to be a team Elijah when I got to the
pros I want to be like Magic Mike
these guys are unleashed this is what I
want to do so you know watching those
guys and you know just take a little bit
of what those guys do it didn't just had
my own stuff to it we had Mike Penberthy
with us in Los Angeles
coming up gotta got me three
championships okay so he told his story
I'd never heard this before you know
Mike was the journeyman for the Lakers
he was there when you guys he won a
couple of titles he's walking to
practice I believe and you were driving
you roll down the window and you say to
him basically no teammate of mine walks
to practice he said you threw him a
handful a wad of cash that was heavy hit
him in the chest and he said it was
probably close to $10,000 was the money
in your glove compartment like where
where was the 10 grand for that year to
please see to that yeah 28.7 27.2 and I
liked your quote where you said they
don't build statues plays it sounds like
it sounds like room services arrived so
I'll let you have your your brunch there
detective yes wheat bran pancakes and
two glass dollars useful for cardio and
I'm gonna do my podcast how much do you
weigh Nia 379 which is too much I came
out of 345 so I'm gonna try to get it
back down to 350
what's the most you ever one problem Oh
401
at the end of last year oh wow my
problem with sandwiches like my kind all
just turkey is cheese actually Oh how
many can you polish on three oh that's
not bad
you know while I'm watching you know my
Netflix shows eat two or three times you
stay over all right well hey great to
talk to you I'm glad that you and Kobe
are still great friends
he's the Immaculate researcher
you know anytime you need me to pull
your numbers I'm there just text me all
right Thank You Shaq Thank You Shaq Shaq
having brunch there what a character
yeah for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR Live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]